when we saw this happen yesterday as we
were on the set preparing for football
night in america chris on the set in
stamford connecticut me on my set here
in west virginia
we all
felt it you could it was palpable the
air went out of the room
and we were minutes before going on the
air live on nbc when dak prescott
suffered a gruesome and grotesque
compound fracture dislocation of the
ankle on the same day alex smith ended
his two-year journey back to the nfl
after a serious compound leg fracture it
happened at that prescott and these
things are
incredibly
rare especially for quarterbacks chris
and it really was a moment i'll never
forget because i could just feel it even
from here i could feel the air go out of
the room in connecticut i felt like i
was punched in the stomach everybody
loves and respects and admires dak
prescott and to have that happen to him
yesterday
was
was
as stunning a moment as i can remember
in 50 years of following football yeah
it hurt it was shocking it really was it
was you know you like you said it was
like alex smith it was like watching joe
theismann back in the day because you
just went oh my gosh first off you know
quarterbacks may be a little bit more
personable than other positions because
they're brought into our home more often
than everything else you know through tv
commercials everything like that uh but
then you know you you worry about the
guy first and dak prescott just being
around him the few times i have been the
last few super bowls
couldn't like him more you can
understand why everybody talks about him
in such a glowing fashion throughout the
cowboys organization uh so so it hurts
from that standpoint and there's so many
things to unpack from this because of
dax franchise tag and all of that but at
the base level yeah you hurt for a guy
you heard for a guy that yes is making a
big paycheck this year but was really
close to really making some serious
money and i've been there and i've been
in his shoes that way and it's
devastating i think that's probably part
of the reason you saw him break down in
tears even more on the golf cart i feel
like all the reality hit him like damn
franchise tag i could have maybe signed
for this money and everything i'm not
trying to be insensitive by any of this
but it just all comes to happen he's
thinking about that man i don't know
about that in that moment okay i think
look when your leg is that messed up and
you know what you have in front of you
and also you recognize and i don't know
how much he processes this but the
reality is
you have and i don't even know he's
aware in the moment that the the break
is so bad that it actually pierces
through the skin that's a serious
situation
that's what happened to alex smith and
that's when and look i'm no doctor but
when you live this long enough and you
then you hear what doctors have to say
team doctors experts in the field
when when that bone
up bursts through the skin and and the
bacteria and other stuff that is on our
skin at all times gets inside of your
body where it is not supposed to be
that creates a very real risk and they
need to be sure and one of the things
they were doing last night cleaning the
wound thoroughly and completely as they
also repaired the compound fracture and
the dislocation to keep infection out
and that is the challenge going forward
the surgery deemed a success dak
expected to leave the hospital today
which is almost as stunning as the
injury itself i thought maybe he would
be there for a little while he was there
straight after the injury happened his
brother posted the picture back in good
spirits and now we'll be recovering at
home when he's released later today but
it is a serious situation
and i think that the biggest reaction in
that moment number one everything you
work for prepared for is done in the
fifth game
you're going away from your teammates
they're going to have to try to win
football games without you and you feel
like you're letting them down i feel
like that
may be the prevailing emotion in that
moment chris i mean you went through
that although
you were probably unconscious for a lot
of it but i think when the dust begins
to settle
the big reaction and the big thought and
the strongest emotion is you've in some
way let your teammates down well it just
it all just piles on it's it's like
that's why i was saying like that's why
i felt like that probably went through
his head i wasn't trying to go like
insensitive there or anything like that
but it just all comes to this boiling
point of like you're in shock like oh my
gosh i can't believe i'm hurt like this
this is unbelievable
oh man i'm not going to be able to play
football anymore man i'm not going to be
around the teammates anymore
oh man how long is it going to take me
to come back from this injury all that
goes into your brain let alone
what does this do to my career it all
comes it's like a like a crazy nightmare
or whatever a dream you know how you you
wake up and you're like man it just was
just little flashes of things that went
through my brain real quick it's kind of
like that and uh it's just it is gonna
be a long road back for him but he's a
guy that we know can handle this and
it's just you know we we hope it's not
you know so serious and that the surgery
went well like you said to where he can
get back to rehab and get back to
somewhat normal dak prescott once again
and how long that takes i don't know but
yeah you know
mike when he went down
just from that sideline view right away
you knew something was wrong and it was
like one of those things where you're
like man that didn't look right the way
he went down and then you kind of saw
the leg and then of course we got the
close view and you were like whoa that's
not straight there that's not good
and i just i can't burn that image out
of my head right now for poor dak
prescott and the dallas cowboys
and i never want to see it again and
when i rewatch that game i'm going to
skip that part there's no reason to see
it there's nothing to be gained by
seeing and i didn't mean to suggest you
were being insensitive about
what he's feeling
to the extent that there's a financial
aspect but you're right that that
notion of contract it's always been
there it never goes away it's been there
with him more so than any other
quarterback or player really in recent
years that's been so much the focal
point of the talk and it really is that
blender where it all is thrown together
it all comes together in one moment
everything he's endured on the field off
the field this stare down
with the cowboys that he was successful
at even though he still didn't get a
long-term contract i still think he did
the right thing and i think he was
successful and we'll be talking about
that in a minute
but
the overwhelming feeling and i agree
with you in that in that specific moment
all those things coming together and now
he has to to to move forward
and
we'll we'll see how it goes we don't
know what the prognosis is we always
hear that the surgery is a success and
at some point we'll hear his recoveries
ahead of schedule but
you know we get numb to it because it's
not part of our lives because next man
up and the game keeps going and we
forget about dak prescott just like we
forgot about ben roethlisberger last
year we forgot about cam newton last
year
people just move forward with football
and it's out of sight out of mind and we
know at some point you'll be back in
sight back in mind but dak prescott's
not going to be
out of mind he may be out of sight we'll
probably see him on the sidelines at
games i suspect he will be around as
much as he can
but like god prescott is he's he's he's
beloved throughout the nfl for
everything he's done on and off the
field and and it's not going to be i
think like other guys where we just we
just forget about him and move forward
well yeah you're right it's not he is
he's got too good of a personality
everybody's seen how good his heart is
everything like that i think also where
everybody feels it's like to the point
you brought up this is a conversation
that's been going on for two years he
was a fourth round pick he came out of
mississippi state he's never made that
big time first round type money and yeah
it's big money he made this year but you
know
there was other money dangled in front
of him that was life-changing that way
and mike i'm going to go back to one
other thing that just you know is my pet
peeve and i just wish this would get
changed and that's the field turf i sit
there again and go
field turf all right i've had this
conversation with my dad and a few other
players lately just it's it's it's the
foot gets stuck in field turf because
guys wear cleats too
and we're not used to seeing these type
of injuries with quarterbacks but dak is
a different type of quarterback he's a
bigger guy who yes will run will have
people on his shoulders and throw them
off and do things like that to where
other quarterbacks just fold and fall
down you know and uh the big thing is
this you injuries usually happen to
running backs receivers people like that
but i just again you know that's my one
of my issues i i don't know if i feel
like these injuries happen as much or as
uh egregiously as they do maybe if we
were on just regular grass fields once
again sorry
and well you know this is a topic that's
come up yeah on several times in recent
weeks that that that foot does get
caught uh and can't get out and that
it's just
it it is still amazing to me when an
incident like this happens
i take a step back and i say
i'm amazed it doesn't happen more often
right i'm amazed it doesn't occur when
all that cluster of huge bodies
is
is just
churning
and all the opposing forces
and at what point does a bone break at
what point does something give way and
it is so much more visible when it's a
compound fracture than when it's a torn
acl tony dungy was making this point
last night that with the torn acl you
never see it
you see that the player
has a problem with his knee yeah
but the knee still looks like a knee the
leg still looks like a leg and i think
that that makes it
so much harder for the rest of us to
just deal with when we when we see that
kind of a graphic injury and you're
right at what point does the the field
turf become a factor and at what point
do the owners recognize that
for the multi-million dollar investment
they make in players in a payroll that
this year is kissing 200 million dollars
just south of 200 million dollars is
there not a better way yeah right to
ensure that that your investment is
protected even if you don't want to
think of your players as human even if
you become completely desensitized to
the constant churning the longer you own
a team the more you know the names and
the faces are going to change what stays
the same is the team what stays the same
as the helmet in the uniform we change
the names on the back of the jerseys all
the time but still
to the extent that those individuals
are employed by you whether it's one
year 10 years or somewhere in between
you should want
to get the most out of those players you
should want to ensure that they're as
safe as possible when they are playing
on the field
that is in the stadium that you own and
that's the one thing chris that i'll
never understand about the nfl why they
don't take every possible precaution and
spend every possible dollar to make sure
their players are as safe as possible on
the surfaces on which they play yeah
well no i don't i don't understand that
either and the numbers show it i mean
you know injuries are 30 more on feel
you know field turf than grass you know
ankle and knee injuries i think it's
it's even a big more staggering number
than that it's it's something like i i i
can't remember exactly right off the top
of my head but yes that is the issue
there is it is a synthetic grass there's
rubber pebbles in it and you wear real
cleats that you would wear
on a grass field
and it just does not give the same way
and the foot can get stuck and i don't
understand it either mike i mean yeah
the nfl they the owners
it's more i think about the fact they
want the field turf because of the
events they want to have in the off
season the concerts and everything like
that to where that'll ruin the grass and
do all that i just wonder do they come
out on end of that when you know okay
yeah you're paying d prescott 31 million
dollars and
you're not gonna get all the services
for that money let alone you know all
the guys that get hurt that you have to
resign on your roster and then also get
hurt the money wasted on that every year
through some of these injuries i i
really would i would wonder what you
know it is make or how much it's making
a difference in these owners lives and
and the the final you know bank number
there
yeah i mean that really is the point
even if
the humanity of the situation does not
affect you as an elderly person who has
owned a football team for 30 years and
they have come and they have gone and
they will come and they will go until
it's time for you to go
you're losing the benefit of 31.4
million dollars right in services for
the balance of the year and if you had
grass on that field who knows what would
have happened and uh and that's an
unfortunate aspect of all of this dak
prescott does make 31.4 million this
year fully guaranteed you know it's
funny how
we get so caught up in the nuances and
we understand the details the average
fan when something like this happens
we'll say does he still get paid well
yes he does his contract is guaranteed
for skill injury and cap he gets every
penny of the 31.4 million the bigger
question is
what happens next year yeah and there
are three options and it's all going to
be influenced by chris by what happens
over the course of the next several
months
they will have until
late february now they can't begin
negotiating contract until after the
season ends
from there until late february
long-term deal for dak or if that
doesn't happen franchise tag deadline
arrives will they use the tag again and
remember this it's 37.68 million for
next year and the salary cap may be as
low as 175 million and that number is
still 37.68 million by rule unless they
would change the rules of the franchise
tag between now
and and the arrival of next year's
franchise tag window which is highly
unlikely he gets a 20 raise over what he
made this year 37.68 million right what
do you do then do you let him hit the
open market at that point does he become
a free agent do you wait to see
what someone else is willing to pay him
before
you offer him a contract this could be
like the cam newton situation
with a twist
where the cowboys
consciously assume the risk that someone
else will pursue him
hopeful that no one else will pursue him
coming off of that injury and you know
what if the pandemic is raging again how
can anyone pursue him you can't bring
him in for a physical you can't bring
him in for a meeting i mean if this
thing rebounds the way that some think
it will
march of 2021 may be the same as march
of 2020. so that's in the cowboys favor
as well and and look
this is just a glimpse of the business
reality that we're going to be dealing
with and whether to what extent dak
prescott recovers from this thing
quickly and completely is going to be a
huge factor yeah in what the cowboys
ultimately choose to do chris yeah i
mean they're going to have to evaluate
this yeah week by week and really kind
of see yes like you know like like you
talked about get the report from the
doctor how did the surgery go they're
really going to have to do their due
diligence here because i would think the
franchise tag is off the table at this
point there there's i don't know i don't
know is it i don't know i just i i just
i just if he's if he recovers if he if
it's a clean break and it's fixed and
he's fine and there's no infections and
he doesn't need any further surgeries
and he's dak prescott that he's always
been
off the table you're right you're right
that that could possibly be you're right
i'm jumping to conclusions by just how
gruesome it looked a little bit
yesterday all right and maybe thinking
of the worst case scenario but if there
is ligament damage if it wasn't the
cleanest break there was if it is to the
like the point where we're getting into
you know april or we're getting into
march and
okay yes he's just really getting out of
the cast and not capable of running or
doing anything like that i just i'm
again i'm not trying to be insensitive
i'm just i have a hard time thinking the
cowboys would do that i would i would
see more of envision of this mic of just
them them figuring out a deal of like
hey let's
let's figure something out because we
really like you we don't know how
healthy you're going to be and here's a
little money because you you might be
the starting quarterback this year but
we're going to kind of let it go and see
here but we're going to have probably a
pretty good backup here just in case
something like that it's it's i i can
envision something like that happening
well but chris i can envision that
prescott continuing to take the maybe he
always has right that this is finally my
shot at free agency and if you don't
believe in me someone else will and as
rodney harrison said last night we were
talking about this there'll be five or
six other teams that will rush to sign
dak prescott that will assume the risk
that it may take a year for him to get
back to 100 but then they have him
beyond that so there's a lot of
uncertainty and and you know what the
very astute
follower of these issues may be
wondering what about the transition tag
that's a way where the cowboys can just
match any offer and there's no two
first-round picks in play here's the
problem transition tag guarantees him a
20 increase just like the franchise tag
so it's still 37.68 million so it would
be the franchise tag or nothing for the
cowboys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports